finland and sweden
should not base their security
in
based on
damaging security of other countries and
their accession to nato can have
detrimentary
consequences and
face some
military and political consequences we
don't see any direct immediate threats
and i think we are really well prepared
we have one of the best armies in europe
we have strong defense
we have a really good international
partners
we are not in a position that we would
get scared because of one statement
there's nothing new that's the old
russian position
they've been telling that for many many
years
russia has always been against and they
have always said that they would have
some measures if finland would join nato
or sweden
there's a war going on in ukraine so we
have to take it seriously there's no
doubt
we don't feel that we are kind of in a
situation that would force us to some
immediate decisions
the most important thing is of course to
see
how the war in ukraine could be ended in
a way that protects ukraine's
sovereignty
i believe
russians have
rather clear political objectives
i don't see any automatic spillover from
that country